for more than 40 years fishing has been
a way of life
today he's struggling to survive
the price of fuel is too high it was 70
rupees a liter now it's more than four
times that the price of Nets have also
gone up and they don't last as long
things are very difficult
fishermen across the country are facing
the same struggle if they don't land a
proper catch they can't cover their
costs debts are mounting Sri Lanka's
worst economic crisis in memory left the
country bankrupt unable to pay for Basic
Essentials like food medicine and fuel
agriculture is the other main earner in
the former war zone but sinapa marinagam
is not finding it easy
we met him drying his Paddy before the
rain set in
once comfortably off he's trying
desperately to survive
we don't have fertilizers or chemicals
they are too expensive and subsidies
have been stopped so costs are high and
the yield is low higher labor and damage
from recent floods have increased the
cost the government isn't buying Paddy
and the middlemen come and offer very
low prices
farmers are coping with multiple hits
including a shortage of fertilizer and
agrochemicals following a ban by the
former president since reversed
fertilizer prices have swung wildly
between a dollar and a hundred dollars
per 50 kilo bag
President Ronald Vikram singer met
farmers in Northern kilenuchi on Sunday
and promised the government would start
buying from them at a fixed price from
next week
but some economists say the government's
handling of the crisis including
implementing IMF conditions has been
disastrous we have been market pricing
energy
we've devalued the rupee our interest
rates went up from six percent to 15.5
percent
and austerity measures by the government
we are seeing so many smes collapse in
the country as well as in the north and
smes are the backbone of the economy
because nobody can survive on such high
interest rates for working capital and
credit communities like this are facing
the worst effects of Sri Lanka's
economic crisis and skyrocketing Global
prices they're struggling to survive and
say government claims of better times
ahead sound like empty promises
Fernandez Al Jazeera palali in Northern
Sri Lanka